alors djamel donc vous êtes au bataclan
à partir du 15 septembre
est ce que c'est le même spectacle à la
cigale on a repris la base du premier
spectacle qui nous passait pas
inintéressante mais l'anglais lu
tellement de succès on a retravaillé
autour et on a trouvé des choses un peu
fade et où il ya des nouvelles choses
bien sûr mais je ne peux répondre par
oui j'ai fait une question assez mais
c'est ça fait traiter les lorientais la
propreté l'interview vous aimez les
chiens jamais les jours dans les
chiottes gère très bien alors le sait le
même metteur en scène oui kader aoun
vous pensez durer jusqu'à noël
si tout se passe bien si tout se passe
bien jusqu'à noël ouais si linda viens
pour me soutenir la viande halal alors
djamel on s'est connu tous les deux il
ya quand même quelques années maintenant
35 ans d'une 25 ans bien sûr une
émission que je faisais à l'époque sur
sur paris dernière sur paris première
lui échapper paris dernière tu as fait
un mission qu'il était bien d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est votre deuxième télé
oui la première cité pêche d'enfer
c'était là c'était un truc tout ça
c'était tout et il est tout bleu et
barbus étaient dix ans de plus non
faussée si vous avez les images se vend
bien pourquoi c'est pas bien si on verra
des images vous avez toujours à la télé
on invite des gens leur montre des
images qui les met mal à l'aise
certes il te plait magnéto
et s'il tient ce soir est un marmaille
là je suis à si tu me prends la tête
joris tous les manières isag il arrête
là avec leur leur technique leur matos
leurs écoles leurs questions et à la fin
j'ai trois journalistes avec blizzard du
genre si genre sous un toit genre si
j'en aurais tu sens bizarre quand genre
terrorisme genre comme u appareil ce
prix-là récit commence à se poser des
questions si vous souhaitez six types
bizarres et je n'ai pas trouvé un petit
meuble était bien là bilson moi je vais
pas je te prêter à ces choses comme ça
comme celle là fait comme ça et coûte
bonbon
donc si jamais là moi aussi je suis
votre copain je suis la banlieue comme
vous un si beau temps mer vous écoutez
j'ai pas par quatre chemins je vais le
bus en coton et les questions je vais
vous parler en toute franchise vos
problèmes économiques sociaux culturels
car je sais c'est pas la peine de me
dire que vous avez d'énormes problèmes
vous assurez parmi les gens normaux
sains
je sais que votre père tâte bottemer que
vous en est réduit à vous servir de
crédit comme moyen de locomotion xbox
pas vrai j'ai les preuves si ça va
chauffer grave j'étais binaire graves
comme but la touche fauve grave tout à
l'heure j'ai regardé jeudi l'opposant à
l'andropause or d'avant duch on vous
voit on n'a jamais voulu d'un cas
l'ensemble qu'eustache d'accord un doute
vous voit la bande du jury je me demande
quelle cellule de qu'elle puisse de mal
à s'insérer par les gendarmes en moi
avec mes caddie ou lui avec sa pub sur
la tête la 12e c'est pas mon père qui
tape ma mère c'est ma marque par nos
pairs
c'était s'est-il quand j'étais en cm2 ça
ouais ouais c'est à dire que c'était un
très très longtemps
je me souviens c'était passionnant
sérieusement ça vous embête de non pas
du tout mais chez à la télé moi où je me
regarde pas j'ai toujours un peu
critique sur ce que je fais j'ai fait
les choses et souvent je ne trouve pas
bien après et là je trouve ça trop bien
être du tout au long du rhône l asko
revient de bach donc c'était la deuxième
télé apprend à pas raconter votre
carrière parce qu'elle a été racontée en
long et en large et une ovale paris
première une autre émission qui était l
émission de nova sur paris première il
ya eu il ya eu h
lpa le cinéma avec son cd puis le ciel
les oiseaux et ta mère qui avait quand
même dix mille 1 million par an 10
millions d'un million 10 millions de
clients la division 2 millions mais mnp
à canal+ c'est sain et labit un alibi
pour vous celle inverse c'est une gifle
et des fonds j'ai vu dans les interviews
vous demander souvent est ce que vous
pensez pas être l'alibi de canal+ moi
j'ai plutôt l'impression que finalement
c'est canal+ que votre alibi pour vous
fait découvrir des canal+ uniquement et
simplement pour l'argent
faut pas l'oublier et les meufs et c'est
ça danse ça a marché
non mais mais toujours bon pour
atteindre plus sérieux on m'a souvent
posé la question ne trouve pas que tu es
là tu es là tu es le contrat de canal +
au qatar au buzz canal+ je pense
vraiment pas je pense que alain de greef
m'a engagé parce qu'ils y croyaient en
moi j'espère enfin je suis sûr même si
je ne dis pas mais c'est un échange de
bons procédés finalement oui de toute
manière comme danse comme dans toute
association qui fonctionne bien tu vois
jj gagner et aussi mais c'est sûr qu'au
début on pouvait se poser la question et
on fera un continent et en fin de compte
je ça veut dire à chaque fois qu'il va
pêcher un bouton vous l applaudir comme
des imbéciles ça j'ai compris le système
auquel il ya une punition aussi dans le
sampler c'est par exemple j'étais un
truc vraiment au mois ou linda dit un
truc vraiment pénible à la punition mais
là messieurs
on peut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
c'est i muvrini voilà moi je vais pas
interdite en corse parce que vous aimez
mais alors c'est toi tu veux dire une
connerie ira ça ira ça ouais et tenter
quand tu dis un truc génial grâce à bond
alors la gloire
vous dites parlait beaucoup de votes
loire les mercedes tapis rouge aux bains
douches et et j'en parle pas à moi sans
légende ils ont fait parler oui oui mais
vous avez quand même il ya un truc plus
intéressant si vous avez quand même une
méfiance paris vous appelez ça le côté
obscur c'est quand même une méfiance de
paris ouvrait un le que ces messages
invitant à trappes dans les yvelines et
on débarque dans dans une jungle
véritablement je suis pas là à faire je
sais très bien comment ça se passe cyril
faible à ton petit malin mais ouais j'ai
tout était inaccessible et d'un coup
tout s'ouvre donc forcément tu te les
filles tu prend de la distance avec les
fils à sauviat maintenant un peu mieux
un peu mieux et je galère encore
vraiment
alors on ne s'attend pas à ce que j'ai
passé avec ça si aujourd'hui une fille
une jeune femme que vous avez draguer ya
cinq ans et qui vous avait chuté drague
à son tour aujourd'hui je la jette plus
aucun intérêt
non non il faut passer non je passe à
autre chose maintenant a lancé céline
que j'ai des choses qu'il ya eu celui
que prendra ta question oui détecter
comment les filles intéressées donnant
un mais je sais pas si je détecte et
fille intéressée moi je suis sincèrement
je suis très naïve de ce côté là je ne
crois pas qu'ils ont détecté comme ça
moi je fonctionne à la blague à part
mais j'ai aimé c'est vrai que que non
non j'ai pas j'habite toujours à trappes
j'ai pas bougé je rencontre les filles
avec qui chante j'ai quand même eu moins
en moins souvent à trappes l'habite
encore là bas niveau tous les soirs
l'exclusion plus tard
passionnant alors il ya une phrase moi
de vous dire mais ce que je trouve très
très bien c'est quand vous parlez de
paris vous dites c'est comme dans le
film quand charlton heston descend du
mont sinaï où il a reçu les dix
commandements vous dit à moïse un bruit
charlton heston quantique est très
symbolique
quand il a reçu les dix commandements il
descend comme ça du il descend du sinaï
voit tous les hébreux en train d'adorer
le veau d'or ça c'est un peu l'image que
vous faites de paris finalement bah
ouais parce que sincèrement
j'arrive là depuis deux trois ans dans
un univers que je connaissais pas c'est
à dire on se faisait grand cas les
matins midis et soirs de toutes les bois
qui vous toutes les boîtes que j'ai fait
sans exception sans exception je me dis
je me faisais recalé en bloc tout papa
toutes les filles sans exception mais on
avait du mal avec les filles aussi
pareil on n'avait pas l'argent qu'il
fallait pour avoir les sables qu'il
fallait on n'était pas dans le coup donc
ont été mis à l'écart et est maintenant
d'un coup tout le monde s'intéresse à
moi et toute notre attention à ce que je
dis c'est formidable
mais joe non on va maintenant finir un
petit peu cette parce qu'après on va
passer une vrai interview on va finir un
peu avec un extrait moi qui m'a beaucoup
plus c'est quand vous étiez à cannes
c'est d'ailleurs comme l'émission paris
dernière réalisée par sylvain bergère
c'est le journal de la nuit et on vous
voit face à face avec le plus grand
comique français laurent gerra magnéto
serge s'il te plaît c'est un monde
vraiment en profiter il y avait la mine
bien des âmes les plus grands du monde
enfin banon 6,6 sur un ton très drôle
effectivement dans le vague parfaite pas
l'air bien dit mais qu'est ce qui montre
à ce que j'ai c'est qu'on peut pas
bouffer 5e caméra allait aussi l'encadré
avec un décor à 2020 la mutation de gène
est lié au parlement face à toi tu
entendras passer l'eau non juste à dire
qu'ils étaient le mec tu vois des mecs
les plus drôles de france voilà ça c'est
vrai la chanson et étudiants bien
accompagné il dit dans des endroits sont
que c'est la classe mais après tout le
monde circule
ouais c'est l'homme le plus grand de
france
on enchaîne alors donc vous avez comme
je disais tout à l'heure vous avez
beaucoup raconté votre légende vous avez
un discours très au point l'air ou à la
télé ou quand on voit son livre
déclarations dans la presse discours
très haut point c'est parce qu'on pose
tout le temps les mêmes caisses voilà
c'est justement ce qu'on va tourner
parce que vous dites que vous avez un
personnage très très construit vous dit
évidemment mon personnage est construite
toute pièce parce que si j'étais comme
lui j'aurai une chambre à sainte anne
depuis depuis longtemps bien évidemment
bien évidemment alors à vous poser des
questions qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
vous poser la télé à ça ça fait plaisir
par contre voilà quoi respect de baisser
un peu la lumière
j'aime pas les cracks marques comme ça
uncanny x aboudou suisse et poissy plus
bas à régis bande d'enfoirés vous êtes
tous avec lui dans l'éducation simple à
vous pensez à quoi là maintenant là tout
de suite plus facilement et franchement
un mois c'est vulgaire donc non mais dis
non non mais c'est bon on peut se lâcher
un peu plus molle m
non non je te jure bon bah je rigole je
suis là comme ça je me demande ce que tu
as posé comme question
bon ben voilà donc qu'est ce que tu
penses ce matin quand tu dois dans la
glace par tu te réveilles la première
chose que tu te dis quant à vous vous
dites pardon je me dis [ __ ] si je
faisais dix centimètres de plus je serai
mannequin
c'est pas faux 10 cm de plus proche tric
trac dans le sun quand vous étiez petit
millier ressembler à qui quand j'étais
petit je voulais ressembler à un tony
montana dans scarface un seul excusez
moi ça vu le film parfait
ouais bien sûr je vous laisse lui comme
plein de mecs dans le quartier excuses
énerve le plus chez vous ce que je
supporte pas c'est difficile icd
essayons de répondre à cette question
bah ouais mon moment que 2 des
subjectivités je pense ouais comme pas
ma subjectivité qu'elle est passée
adéquat que des mots compliqués j'avais
du vocabulaire est ce que c'est ce que
vous supportez pas chez moi qu'est-ce
que vous supportez pas chez moitié
sauveteurs pourquoi tu t'habilles tout
le temps noir pour être sûr qu'on me
reconnaisse
non non c'est pas pour ça arrêt jane
birkin c'est pourquoi pas mentir parce
que samassa massy ouais en fait à un
gros là bas non non non non c'est dispo
depuis quelques mois j'ai un côté salman
le nord c'est un mât simba le noir sur
noir c'est bien sûr la preuve qu est-ce
que vous supportez pas chez linda j'ai
vraiment pour l'instant rien du tout je
supporte tout pour le moment
et comme le dirait quand vous êtes vous
senti le maître du monde est ce qu'un
jour vous avez le sentiment d'être
vraiment un demi dieu de toute modestie
jamais non jamais et aujourd'hui ce qu'
il ya quelque chose que vous
souhaiteriez à voir absolument
que voudriez par dessus tout vous ne
pouvez pas acheter qui vous tenterait ou
qui vous ferait extrêmement plaisir et
que vous pouvez pas posséder la suite
comme s'amuse les appartements ils ne
voient pas
je cherche mais non non quelle insulte
qui vous a fait le plus mal en fait dans
votre vie espèce de sale arabe
ouais enfin que m'a fait plus mal c'est
le truc que je supporte pas du tout que
j'ai entendu un mois en mois maintenant
mais je jure mais mais mais ça c'est
vraiment ils tinrent aux lois entendre
et quand vous écrivez le photographe
vous écrivez maintenant ça dépend si
c'est des filles ou des garçons et des
arbres si c'est une fille gemma recours
aux bisous jamais de vous je fais un
coeur si c'est un garçon je marque que
dégage de booth un dégage est ce que
vous êtes déjà sortie avec la copine un
copain pour voir si vous avez un peu de
moral quand même si vous les ouvreuses
je mets les pieds dans le plat là c'est
d'actualité merde merde
ah non pas du tout jamais je suis avec
le copain ou une copine avec le copain
d'une grande colline non encore moins
bon si par exemple vous trouvez un porte
monnaie que 500 francs devant partait à
vous faites quoi
j'ai maintenant je leur en avons voulu
garder ouais c'est honnête millions
maintenant je rends moi je le rends pas
ce que je pense à la pauvre
j'étais en turquie et je trouve et
s'était hissé tgt j'avais pas encore
autant d'argent qu'aujourd'hui et je
trouve un portefeuille mais super blindé
d'argent plein et épais tousser et
c'était une demoiselle qui étaient là
qui travaillait dans l'hôtel où j'étais
j'ai elle voit elle vendait des
pellicules je me rappelle je prends le
portage qui jure en jurant page du range
e rang paris je rentre en page orange
durant pas et j allais à les juges en
jeu lurgi vga et je fais la queue pour
lui rendre sur la queue pour lui rendre
est un moment donné je te jure juge
alors j'arrive jurant le portefeuille et
puis judy excusez moi pour avoir cette
pellicule mais je veux marlins josh
gorges plus loin je suis un gars comme
ça j mais pourquoi bordel de merde
la sla déjà ça m'a énervé qu'est ce que
vous seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le
grand amour à ça ça se discute
avant ça c'est parce que tu peux rien
faire d'autre moitié je peux pas retenu
plombier mécaniciens par le débiteur du
matin et finir à 17 heures mais pour
elle
peut-être ah si vraiment c'est le grand
amour un grand talent grande quant à moi
je lâche tout donc le grand amour né
n'est pas encore arrivé jamais l 1 01
euro
jamal 1 0 est ce que si vous étiez ruiné
plus du tout d'argent enfin vraiment
plus une thune est ce que vous seriez
prêt à tourner dans un film porno au
aucune chance à quoi un truc très simple
jamais je serai je serai ruine et gérons
nos régimes famille assez solidaires et
avec les ya un problème ils sont là que
jamais obligé je suis un mais je pense
est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau
ensuite je le fais mais que ouais c'est
ça faut pas arrêter
comment les questions alors c'est toi
qui écris les questions combinaison le
contrôle et les questions de licences tu
veux les faux-pas faut prendre du
doliprane parce qu'il ya la douleur
constante et la douleur tout d'abord si
pour prendre mon fils est assez stable à
12 heures et tu prends ça fallait
présenter une homosexualité ou une fille
très laide que je leur souhaite vitré
rennes où un mec très beau vous
choisiriez quoi j'irai plus dans la
savonnette mois mais entre une miss
monde et trois miss france vous voyez
quoi bon je prends trois miss france 3
mission dès janvier pour l'énième 1.3
miss france si vous aviez 24 heures avis
vous pourriez quoi on vous dit vous
allez mourir dans 24 heures foyer quoi
ils vo presse pierre bleue qu'est ce que
tu veux mais c'est la vérité je vais
auprès de maman moi je reste avec l 24
heures il attrape comme ça je le
reconnais
voulu monter jamais à votre maman non
pourquoi l'une des rares personnes à qui
je mens pas pourquoi parce que le sait
tout de suite quand je mens je fais des
petits quand je mangeais chappille un
peu non moi je dois je vais y travailler
ah ouais de ma gueule
il ya un truc chez vous qui est qui est
tristement parce que aujourd'hui dans
l'est à la télé à la radio les gens'
plus dire qu'ils sont croyants
catholiques se sont un peu passé de mode
un peu ringard c'est les gens comme vous
et c'est des gens comme vous qui osez
dire finalement beaucoup plus que les
catholiques
ben moi je suis musulman je suis croyant
évidemment je fais un petit peu des c
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'en ce
moment on n'a pas trop la cote de ce
côté là les intégristes ne font pas une
super bonne publicité non plus hein nous
non plus les cathos les intérêts s'ils
ne font pas une beuverie on l'aimé on
parle un peu plus de nous que nous en ce
moment
excuse moi je moi mais c'est vrai que
non j'ai aucun problème avec ça j'ai été
baigné là dedans mes parents moi mon
moins élevé avec avec ses traditions là
je suis musulman je l'assumé mais c'est
un truc que je vais très bien parce que
l'islam est une religion qui est très
très tolérant très ouverte et et je la
kiffe
je trouve que c'est très c'est là c'est
la classe de musulmans et vous buvez pas
vous fumez pas noir je bois pas je ne
fume pas c'est sérieux les gens vous
pratiquez les cinq prières par jour par
exemple j j'essaye du mieux que je peux
mais comme je rentre tard des fois c'est
maintenant c'était quand la dernière la
cgt le mois de novembre dernier un vrai
dans leurs prières dans la lah c'était
ce matin avait donc 5
c'était entre 8 et 9,9 et 5,1 ce matin
je me suis levé et est 10 heures et tu
sais d heure précise à laquelle furent
hier hélas
demande la dernière à la dernière
c'était ce matin alors j'en ai encore
quatre attrapés l'air d'être très très
disent être incarnée en quoi moi ouais
tu viens gobain annonce au nom si je
n'aurais pas interdire quelque chose ce
sera endigué par un guépard c'est bien
que j'aie pas c'est bien facile avec la
classe le guépard dans la savane faut il
est bien habillé le guépard il a des
beaux habits est-ce que vous avez menti
depuis le début de cette émission non
franchement non pas pour répondre
toujours non pas encore mais c'est bien
je suis ravie merci c'était l'odeur et
de lumière alors avant avant de passer à
leurs invités suivants mais bien entendu
vous restez avec nous je voudrais pardon
vous lisez je suis là ça moi je voulais
dire que c'est général ont surpris par
ce genre de question parce que je suis
pas l'habitude comme les pauses voilà
c'est bien thierry cain aiguilles alors
à vendredi qu'un mec bien je me
comprends avant de passer à notre invité
suivant bien entendu bien sûr djamel
vous restez avec nous cet investissement
charles millon challenge le bas on va
rien et on va regarder
c'est facile en effet monsieur discute
chars bien tu attends mais il arrive
mais avant avant charles millon je
voudrais quand on regarde un extrait du
spectacle jamel en scène donc à la
cigale et qu'on va retrouver à partir du
15 septembre au bataclan
magnéto serge nom des six confiance
c'est peu dire arrête quand même
maintenant
ares de décorer avec nick bubb les
gargamel pas parlé on s'est dit prête à
chanter c'est pas chantier fait
constamment lundi matin
lebrun sa mère denis chez moi pour
qu'elles portent d un petit truc
comme disait pas chez moi le petit
prince a dit avant une chimie et c'est
pas grave mais je vais revenir plus
lourde 20 du rendement mardi matin veut
pas sa mère le prince et plus ça demain
sont venus chez moi pour qu'on va faire
a foutu comme j'étais déjà en train de
faire un foot
les petits princes a dit abu dis je te
tuera foot c'est pas grave encore
dimanche pour venir dur dans trois rues
du mamrot pas du matin le train sa mère
sa tante amex connaît pas et puis un
autre mec sont venus chez moi pour que
je leur rende leur âge on m'avait prêté
et comme je vais gaspiller tout l'argent
qu'ils avaient prêté le petit prince a
dit abonnés disputons agent de me prêter
jamais de ma place par appel
mais la charge de vous il va partir du
15 septembre au matin clan savate eagles
étaient bourrés de charme
ouais hein comme on dit chez moi c'était
une femme aimée mais le bataclan cccc un
autre pari il ya beaucoup plus et soir
quatre mois et on attend 80 mille
personnes ah ouais donc je vous en
supplie
venez ça nous on sera là non sera parmi
80 merci très bien j'accueille
maintenant notre avis la suivante jamais
avec touchant billon